simon papa tara beaux jours yannick noah
merci d'être avec nous en direct
marseille c'est une chanson sur le grand
père ouais cette chanson sur sûrement
grand père paternel ou acquis qui est
parti qu'il est revenu quelques années
après ils me rendent visibles mais je
vous ai entendu dire yannick que vous
l'avez rencontré après sa mort oui oui
c'est une histoire assez personnelle
mais maintenant qui est devenu une
chanson effectivement c'est une
expérience assez bouleversante pour moi
que de retrouver un matin mon grand père
qui était décédé quelques années avant
c'est quelque chose qui m'avait vraiment
marqué et qui me marquent toujours qui
me marquera de toute façon toute ma vie
yann vous dites les riches doivent
donner être riche c'est surtout donné je
pense oui je pense que quand on a la
possibilité de donner donc ça veut dire
qu'on a quelque chose je pense qu'il ya
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de gens qui
ont la possibilité de le faire
il se trouve que à travers notre
association on a la possibilité de
rassembler un maximum de gens alors sont
les gens qui travaillent avec nous ce
sont les gens qui nous aiment et sont
aussi des gens qui nous soutiennent en
venant nous suivre depuis des années
dans nos différentes aventures nos
spectacles est bon mais aujourd'hui on
se retrouve à marseille pour ce concert
pour la première fois en dehors de paris
parce que jusqu'à présent notre tennis
concert qui est toujours au zénith de
paris et pour la première fois nous
sommes ici au dôme à marseille on va
jouer ce soir donc tennis concert pour
les enfants de la terre donc pour
l'organisation que dirige votre maman
marie claire vous aider les enfants
alors tout le prix de la soirée où il ya
du tennis à une exhibition comme
d'habitude avec mansour bahrami je pense
oui et d'autres vedettes
allez vous chantez aussi
une exhibition avec avec mon sourire
vraiment notre l'ami des enfants de la
terre qui avec à chaque fois qu'on a
besoin et on va faire notre spectacle
habituel de finisse avec les clowneries
et qui ensuite un spectacle avec tribal
jam avec jocelyne beroard charlelie le
groupe s'amuse à mme bien entendu et
puis et puis d'autres disent surprises
et bien sûr le groupe a de portefeuille
il ya yannick vous parlez des maisons
tendresse pour les enfants de la terre 6
km et en tendresse bien nous travaillons
avec des hôpitaux de paris
debré truchot et et necker est en fait
souvent des enfants qui vient de subir
des opérations dont les parents sont
assez loin ont besoin de récupérer et on
prend ces enfants là le temps qu'ils
récupèrent nous travaillons aussi avec
la dass qui lorsqu'il ya des problèmes
et des urgences en fait le temps
d'organiser de s'organiser quand il
s'agit de familles nombreuses de
fratries bon ben on reprend récupère des
enfants dans ces maisons
le temps de trouver une solution pour
alors les enfants peuvent rester dans
nos maisons entre une semaine et six
mois ou même des années pour certains
voient là nous avons cinq maisons en
france et ce sont des maisons qui sont à
travers un peu éparpillés dans la france
en général dans la nature et on appelle
ça les maisons trappe tendresse parce
que même si il ya bien sûr le suivi
médical sur place
nous avons aussi à coeur de leur donner
un environnement familial et une chaleur
humaine qui est souvent très nécessaire
dans ces cas là il y aura merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous donc ce soir au
dôme
merci par les enfants de la terre ça
fait plaisir et on vous retrouve aussi
le 5 décembre l'olympia c'est ça oui
voilà à marseille et au dôme à marseille
a appris à l'olympia à paris on descend
bas l'après-midi et bonne soirée à tous
merci et bon